hey gang well the new rockstars I'm Sam
basher and Deadpool 2 is upon us and I
was fortunate enough to grab a early
screening of the film and I'm here to
report back if you've missed the
numerous Deadpool 2 trailer breakdowns
we'll go check them out before hidden
the theaters I know most of you probably
are very excited to sit down with your
popcorn your sour patch kids and enjoy
this film but if you want to hear some
spoiler free thoughts on the movie
before the trailers start listen up
don't worry
totally spoiler free thoughts for this
movie quickie overview I very much
enjoyed this movie the first one I
absolutely loved in this film does a
great job following up everything that
made Deadpool the first one fantastic
but let's be specific here one of this
film's strengths is the action Boyle boy
does Deadpool part do lean into that our
rating and with the mix of humor and the
direction from david leitch co-director
of John wick if you didn't know and solo
director of atomic blonde the fight
sequences in this film have really
stepped up their game from movie movie
sure the action in the first film was a
pretty stellar I'm a big fan of it but
this film improves upon the first film
by playing with weights healing powers
in new fun ways and the cinematography
is able to capture the incredible fight
choreography that really solidifies
Deadpool as more than a crash-test dummy
with jokes but as a certified killing
machine work with him out he did it he
doesn't just need swords or guns he can
take you out with just about anything on
top of that the way that cable Domino
and the rest of the X forces action is
realizing the film definitely makes this
one of my favorite team-up movies
especially in the superhero genre but
just in general I very much enjoyed this
this actually leads me to my next
strengths for the film the cast these
actors not only nail their
interpretations of these classic comic
book characters and they also play off
of each other really well who would have
thought that one of my favorite new
trios in cinema would be Domino cable in
Deadpool
I'm not mad about it but I'm just saying
I didn't expect that to happen
sassy beats thank you and the writers
from making Domino such a strong
character you're great on Atlanta and
I'm happy that you're in more things and
Josh Brolin it's not cool that you get
to be in two Marvel movies in one year
especially ones that I really love and
that you nail each role you gotta let
other people act sometimes in all
seriousness Josh Brolin Kilda and mad
props to the VFX team who were able to
bring all the weird physical attributes
of cable to life and not only a
believable way but in a badass I now
kind of want his I kind of way just
saying it would be pretty cool
it isn't easy so I commend you both and
on top of that at the end of the day
this is Ryan Reynolds movie and boy does
he kill it we come to these movies to
not only see some mind-blowing action
scenes but also to laugh our butts off
and of course mr. Reynolds brings his
a-game the fourth wall breaking humor is
alive and kicking in any scene that he's
in he shines this actually is me pretty
well into my third point which is the
emotional core of this movie it's there
it's strong and it might be my favorite
part of the movie the first film
resonated so well with me because not
only did it give us some bone crunching
action and a chuckle or two but also
there's a believable and grounded love
story in this film we revisit the same
love story between Vanessa and way to
explore it and we also get to dive into
cables back story wise cables so upset
and why is the on this mission in the
past well you have to wait and see the
way these two characters go about
dealing with their respective stories
really drew me into the movie X makes me
want to go real watch the first film and
immediately go watch the second one
again just for fun speaking of fun I
want to give a shout out really quick
two empires trips back now guys this is
a burlesque Star Wars themed show that's
been touring Australia and has been a
hit is now coming to California this
month that's incredible now this is
complete parody of Star Wars it's a
whole ball of fun and actually it's been
touring in Australia for quite some time
playing to sold-out crowds since 2011
it's got a strong cult following there
that is the first times to be playing
the United States as well with the
original Australian cast no burlesque
just to be clear doesn't mean stripping
it's just an exaggeration or parody of
something in this case it's a highly
produced and technical variety show with
the elements that are incredible funny
and theatrically stunning now the show's
creator Russell be teased a huge Star
Wars fan and seeks to honor the classic
franchise by dropping its characters in
this outrageous parody guys if you have
a love of Star Wars you're gonna want to
check out this show especially when its
train in California but there will be a
national tour starting very soon so make
sure you check out the link in the
description to grab tickets and also
check out when new dates are added
whether you're a fan of Star Wars or not
age 18 to 80 Empire strips back is a fun
night out you want a date night idea
there you go you're welcome straight
from new rock stars you're not gonna
want to miss out make sure you check out
the link in the description down below
and tell us how you liked it now it is
worth mentioning that this film isn't
totally perfect no film is really but my
criticisms are
small potatoes in comparison to how much
I enjoyed it what I will say is that
this film does try to be more of an
action comedy rather than a comedy
action movie and it does succeed however
I do think the biggest charge of the
first deadpool film for me was the humor
and while this film is still filled with
top-notch comedy it doesn't lean more
into the action while still thoroughly
entertaining i was a bit let down by the
slight lack of yolks i will also say
that at times it doesn't feel very
balanced it is centered on weight but it
does take a while for the story of the
movie to really kick in the gear that
being said everything that we do get
leading up to the story beginning does
pay off nicely and it still hadn't
engaged but overall i dug this movie i'm
seeing again later this week and not for
breakdown purposes either i just really
enjoyed it and i want to see it again
but that's it for me go enjoy Deadpool 2
and if you've seen it already please
don't spoil it in the comments for the
people who have not seen it yet I would
like to add that you should definitely
stay in your seats during the credits
you don't want to miss some a + post
credits scenes no spoilers I promise be
sure to LIKE this video comment and
subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns for everything Marvel DC
walking dead probably Game of Thrones
you know the deal I'm Sam bachelorettes
and bash on Twitter and I'll see you
guys next time
[Music]